hello everyone and welcome to the first
game we'll be covering from the
meltwater Champions Chester finals it is
with the white pieces against Arjun
eriggaisi and it's really a spectacular
game at one point one of the players uh
just gives up a piece for two pawns uh
basically I think just because it's a
game one to see uh you know uh what will
happen uh you know uh if the opponent's
in a good mood maybe maybe he wins this
one then he just carries it all the way
if he loses one then maybe he plays the
second one a bit more uh carefully uh
but uh yeah it's uh it's wild game then
it takes a completely different turn a
wrong turn if you will uh so let's uh
let's check it out do that with the
white pieces opens with C4 he goes for
the English opening and we have C6 sort
of the Karo Khan versus the English uh
setup Knight to F3 Pawn to D5 and the G3
now preparing to film get to the light
Square Bishop uh G6 and queen to A4 now
penny the C Pawn so C catras on D5 is
the idea Arjun uses this to advance his
Pawn all the way to D4 and Duda takes
this opportunity to advance his Pawn all
the way to B4 with Bishop to G7 now
trying to exploit this diagonal and of
course the bishop to B2 countering um
Arjun strong bishop and G7 with Pawn to
E5 grabbing more space in the center and
pawn to D3 stopping any E4 ideas we have
Knight to E7 and now uh there is a game
that were Knight beta D2 was played but
here we have Bishop to G2 by Duda and it
is now as of move uh eight that we have
a completely new game so the game
continued castles Castles by both sides
uh Bishop to E6 and now Knight B to D2
so just a very normal developing moves
Knight to D7 we have Queen back to C2
making room 48 Pawn we have Ponta A5 and
now Ponte A3 we have H6 now preparing
some future G5 ideas and now Knight the
B3 kind of forcing blacks to decide
whether he wants to advance the pawn to
A4 or captron B4 here Arjun advances the
pawn to A4 and now you were you'd
probably think Duda would just bring the
Knight back Knight B to D2 but I'm
probably gonna use this for the
thumbnail
uh dude that just plays Knight B
captures on D4 and it's not nothing
weird you grab two points for a piece a
sure black is better but only if black
plays this
um perfectly so let's see uh did Arjun
play this perfectly e captures on D4
Knight captures on D4 and not Knight the
F5 and here a very interesting position
where you could capture an E6 and
interestingly even if you didn't just
sacrifice material capturing an E6 looks
like such a great move you create all of
these weaknesses that you can later
exploit but uh a Duda does not go for
the bishop he plays Knight captures on
F5 his idea being that now if Bishop
captures you can just grab a whole lot
of space just Bishop captures King
captures E4 you go after the bishop
after Bishop E6 then uh E4 D4 and you
have a massive control here in the
center for for your sacrifice piece so
this was his idea but after Knight
captures on F5 uh Arjun said nope that's
not happening he played G captures an F5
sort of voluntarily opens up his King
but he has now control over E4 and he
says you are not gonna start pushing in
the center here uh so Duda plays Bishop
captures on G7 King captures and Rook
after D1 he has to play E3 D4 and at
least get something for his sacrificed
piece Queen to F6 and now Pawn to E3
with Knight to E5 this is a beautiful
move by Arjun uh as now D4 is impossible
the C4 Pawn would just be captured so
Queen to E2 preparing Queen E2 Rook to
C1 adding more Defenders to the C4 Pawn
so he can get this D4 move in but Arjun
takes care of that very nicely Rook 838
now Rook 8 to C1 again preparing D4 but
now just Pawn to B5 now the C4 Pawn is
it already attacked so if D4 just Knight
captures on C4 so C counters on B5 C
captures on B5 and now Rook the C5 a
very nice Rook lift by Duda going after
the B5 phone and here the position is
much much better it's straight out
winning for Arjun there's really nothing
to worry about other than the fact that
you are playing rapid Against the World
Series Championship candidate uh and uh
well a former World Chase Champion a
candidate and he is a very strong player
and what you should play here is Bishop
to B3 you attack the rook and once The
Rook moves as you kind of want to keep
defending that D3 Pawn once The Rook
moves You're Gonna Play Knight D7 with
tempo attack the rook and once this Rook
moves now offer a rook trade along the
only open file on the board that is the
C file and the just uh cement your
advantage but after Rook the C5 origin
played Knight captures on D3 He thought
the tactics were working in his favor
and the idea is of course that if Ro
captures then Bishop to C4 attacks the
rook and the queen is an E2 that's gonna
be a big problem but he missed one very
important defensive resource from Duda
uh so dude that just played Rook
captures on D3 and after Bishop C4 Duda
found a very nice move basically the
only move that allows him to continue
the game so just uh to test you guys if
you are if you are present in the game
feel free to pause the video and try to
find the only move that doesn't lose for
Duda while I give you a couple of
seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting uh the
only move that doesn't lose for white
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is Bishop to D5 this
is the only move uh what you've done
with this move is uh you've disconnected
the the Rooks basically and now Bishop
characters and D3 is the only move if
you don't play this right away then if
white gets a move you will simply
capture on C4 and all of Black's ideas
are gone so Bishop captures on D3 must
be played Queen captures on D3 and now
Rook the D6 trying to quickly double up
on the D file but he's just not in time
King to G2 and now what do you play the
problem is now if you go Rook to d8
there's just Queen captures on B5 you
have all the time in the world to get
off the D file so Queen to beat you
Arjun now goes after the A3 phone now if
the White Queen moves you can just start
capturing pawns here and if you create a
pass Pawn here that's going to be very
important Queen main characters on F5 he
even gives up the F5 pawn and now Rook
the F6 he thought okay this Pawn is only
in the way of my attack and now if the
White Queen moves I'm gonna be attacking
the F2 Pawn but the queen moves with
check and now the only move for Arjun to
continue playing this is King to h8 it's
an ugly move but you have to play this
point is that you still have
um pressure on the F2 square and now
after Bishop to F3 the only way to
defend properly you will uh face Rook d8
now the other Rook is coming to D2 but
not not very very quickly because if
this Rook ever moves then Rook to see it
will be deadly so it will be a very
complicated game white would be better
something like E4 would happen and then
well if Queen captures an A3 just E5 and
white continues pushing you you would
probably trade Queens here captures
captures captures and captures and you
would have this Rook end game where
white is up a pawn white has two Pawn
Islands black has three Pawn islands and
the white it definitely has winning
chances here whether he would be able to
win this white black already has a pass
Pawn on A4 that's uh that's a different
question but that was the only way to
play this with black however after Rook
to G6 he allows uh Duda a spectacular
move uh that do that plays pretty much
instantly and that is Queen to E4 uh why
this move is so strong you might think
well uh the move is so strong because
you no longer have to worry about the F2
Pawn that's that's one thing and the
other thing is that if Queen captures an
A3 then you lose the game terribly look
at this queen captures an A3 and now
what was the idea Queen to D4 with check
and now once the king moves Rook the C3
and the black queen is trapped that was
duda's idea and that's why Queen to E4
is so strong now the queen is trapped
because if you play Queen B1 uh Queen A1
or queen to B2 doesn't really matter
just Bishop captures on F7 and you will
lose the queen whatever black plays if
the Rook uh if the king captures then
you can easily just check the king and
pick of the queen and if the Rook
captures there's even Rook the C8 check
and now if you move the king you get
checkmated Rook dh8 will be Checkmate
and if you don't if you play Rook to f8
then we just trade captures captures and
queen captures on V2 Duda would be up uh
well he he would have a queen for a for
a rook so after Queen the E4 Rook the F6
was played but now Duda already has too
much a queen to C2 uh Rook to C2 attacks
the queen queen to B1 and now Queen to
G4 with check King to hate and now again
Queen to D for attacking The Rook so
basically saying you Captain C2 I'm
gonna capture on F6 but there is nothing
better
uh if you if you just repeat King the G7
then something like Bishop to E4 can be
played and again not not a lot for black
to do here so after Queen D4 Queen
captures and C2 was played Queen
captures on F6 black is still up the
exchange however after King to G8 E4
cutting off the Queen's uh reached
over this diagonal Queen to C1 now
guarding the H6 Pawn but now Pawn to H4
we have Queen captures and A3 you would
love to stay on this diagonal but you
have to create some counter play
otherwise you're just gonna lose but now
Queen to G6 with check not just grabbing
the H6 Pawn this is a a good example if
you just grab the H6 Pawn then maybe you
allow Queen to B2 then the this diagonal
is covered and uh maybe you allow black
into the game the pass Pawn will now
start marching forward this way you do
everything with Tempo Queen to G6 check
as the F7 Pawn is pinned that's a weird
arrow and now after King date shade
Queen captures again with checking the
Jade Queen G6 checking they trade Queen
to F6 check King the G8 and now Pawn to
H5 and he was in this position animal 41
that Arjun arigasi resigned to the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
he was also extremely low on clock uh I
do that had some four minutes Arjun had
some 30 seconds on the clock and there
really isn't anything to try H6 and
queen G7 Checkmate is coming you black
cannot grab hold of this diagonal and
even if you try something like H7 let's
say H6 threatening Checkmate and Rook G
then you give up this pawn and then
after Queen captures on F7
King characters on H6 uh like Queen
captures and G8 you're down a full Rook
of course this is resigns but yeah he
didn't wait for that after age five he
resigned and the first game of their uh
four game match goes to Yang shished of
Duda uh so yeah that's the first game
that I decided to cover I thought it was
a really nice one uh as okay uh Arjun
was a right uh straight out of the out
of the opening pretty much dude I went
for that very risky peace sacrifice but
Arjun spent a lot of time he couldn't
figure out how to get out of this and
then he allowed this bishop to D5 move
which basically brought Duda back into
the game and I particularly enjoyed this
uh moment here where after this check
this uh queen queen T4 move was played I
mean that that was just spectacular just
uh completely denying this A3 Pawn to
Arjun because of that beautiful line
where the black queen just gets captured
uh so there you have it that's what it's
like to play against the uh can ended
its tournament a participant that that
is Young shift of Duda the former canvas
term and of course we'll see what
happens in the next one uh but yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
I would like to thank Jonathan Bradley
Christopher Norris the Microsoft Mikhail
arboy and Fernando Gibson for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank you for watching and I will see
you soon continuing to check up on your
wonderful suggestions uh and continuing
the coverage of the Melt weather
Champions Chester finals uh thank you
all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day